I was given the Autobiography of Malcolm
X in college and his life just
fascinated me in terms of the person he
became he had a character that you know
grown up in the south seeing some of the
things I saw the relationships between
black and white seeing the Ku Klux Klan
march on the beach and questioning and a
lot of things and feeling insecure and
all these things say man I want that
strength and that's what led led to me
not not standing because I got to the
point where you know what I don't
believe this
and I don't like what I see so I want to
make a choice to to do something about
it
when I made that decision you didn't
have social media so it was easy for if
there was support if the media chose not
to show that they didn't have to show it
now it's hard to hide if there's an
overwhelming amount of support which
there has been it would be too obvious
and blatant to ignore it I think I think
protest is one of the strongest
instruments that we have and what better
place to get your message out you're on
top of your game top profession and you
have something to say I'm either NFL the
NBA they do it all the time
they're promoting their causes whether
it's AIDS awareness education they use
that platform so we're people we attacks
just like anybody else we're told to
vote to have a voice so what's the
problem so it's nice to see people that
they're willing to go out and disturb
the system because they care about
something and if you want to be heard
you have to somewhat be a disturbance
racism oppression should never be
possible it should be collected and I
think people are becoming more aware of
that and it's hard to keep people quiet
because of social media
they like I say the video and they're
talking about it and people are really
looking at that and then they're
speaking out they're still voice because
otherwise we didn't have that voice